Welcome to the second
set of presentations
on age word problems.
I have one typed out here.
Let's see what it says.
It says, Salman- that's
me- is 108 years old.
And so this is clearly at some
vast time in the future.
And this'll only happen if my
caloric restriction works out.
But Salman is 108 years old.
Jonathan is 24 years old.
How many years will it take
for Salman to be exactly 4
times as old as Jonathan?
Well, let's figure
this one out.
What we're trying to solve for
is how many years will it take.
So let's use the
variable y, for years.
So y equals years until, let's
just say Sal, for short.
Sal is 4 times Jonathan's age.
Well, if today, I, or Sal, if
Salman, it's hard to speak
in the third person.
If Salman is 100 years old
today, in y years, Salman
will be 108 plus y is
equal to Sal in y years.
We'll say y years.
Sal in y years is going
to be 108 plus y.
And then Jonathan in y
years, that's pretty easy.
He's going to be 24 plus y.
So that's, I'll say
Jon for short.
In y years.
Not years.
y years.
And what else does
the problem say?
It says, in how many years
would take for Salman to be
exactly-- I should put that in
another color for emphasis--
Exactly 4 times as
old as Jonathan?
Well, and the exactly
is important.
Because Salman is already
more than 4 times
as old as Jonathan.
But they want to figure out
exactly when is Salman going to
be 4 times as old as Jonathan.
Well, in y years Salman is
going to be 108 plus y.
So we know that.
108 plus y.
And after y years, he's
going to be 4 times
as old as Jonathan.
Exactly 4 times.
And Jonathan's going to
be 24 plus y years old.
And now we just
solve the equation.
Get 108 plus y is
equal to 4 times 24.
Well, 4 times 25 is 100.
And we can subtract
4 from there.
So it's 96.
Plus 4y.
And now we just solve
this equation.
We get 3.
3, I'm going to skip some
steps, because I think this
part is easy for you.
3y will equal 108 minus 96.
So we get 3y is equal to,
what is that, 12, right?
So y is equal to 4.
So our algebra has told us that
in 4 years Salman is going
to be exactly 4 times
as old as Jonathan.
Let's see if that's true.
Well, if Salman is 108
right now, in 4 years
he's going to be 112.
And if Jonathan is 24 right
now, in 4 years he's
going to be 28.
And let's see.
28 times 4 is 80 plus 32.
Yep, exactly.
He'll be 112.
Looks like that problem worked.
Excellent.
Let's do another one.
Hope you didn't hear that,
it was my stomach growling.
See how hard I work
on this site?
Don't even eat properly.
Let's do another problem.
I'll type it in
green this time.
Tarush is 5 times as old as
Arman is today, 85 years ago.
We're dealing with
huge swathes of time.
85 years ago.
Tarush was 10 times
as old as Arman.
How old is Arman today?
Let's see if we can tackle
this quite interesting
problem, I think.
Settings.
Pen tool on.
OK.
Well, I think this might be
useful to do one of those
charts like we did in the
first video presentation.
Well, we're trying to solve
for how old is Arman today's.
So let's say Arman.
And we're going to have today.
And we're going to have,
what's the other time
period we're dealing with.
We're dealing with
85 years ago.
So, let's say.
In a galaxy far, far away.
OK, Arman and Tarush.
Well, we're trying to solve
for how old is Arman today's.
So let's just make that
x, for simplicity.
It says Tarush is 5 times
as old as Arman today.
So let me underline that.
Tarush is 5 times as
old as Arman today.
So if Arman is x, that tells us
that Tarush is going to be 5x.
85 years ago.
So, 85 years ago, well, Arman
is x today, then 85 years ago,
Arman would have
been x minus 85.
And if Tarush is 5x today, then
Tarush would be 5x minus 85.
I just subtracted 85
from the current age.
Because we're going 85
years in the past.
And now we have this extra
piece of information.
Which tells us that 85
years ago, Tarush was 10
times as old as Arman.
So this number is going to be
10 times more than this number.
That's what that
sentence tells us.
85 years ago, we're
in this situation.
Tarush, which is this, was
10 times older than Arman.
We just write that
out algebraically.
85 years ago, Tarush
is 5x minus 85.
And the sentence tells us that
he was 10 times older than
Arman, who is x minus 85.
Now we just solve the equation.
We get 5x minus 85 is
equal to 10x minus 850.
And then you get-- and I'm
going to do this, skip some
steps, just to confuse you-- 5x
is equal too-- well, I think
I just confused myself.
5x is equal to 850 minus 85.
Let's see, what's 850 minus 85.
It'll be 35 less than 800.
So we could say that
5x-- 35 less than 800.
30 less than 800 gets 770.
So 765.
And then x is equal
to, let me see.
5 goes into 70.
1 times 5.
26.
5 times 5 is 25.
15.
So x is equal to 153.
We have some
long-lifespanned people.
So we get the solution that
Arman is 153 years old.
Today.
Let's see if that makes sense.
Well, if he's 153, then,
no, that can't be right.
Because then he's 5.
Huh.
Well, actually I'm
almost out of time.
Let me see where I might
have messed up on this.
If Arman is x, Tarush is 5x.
That makes sense.
Oh, right, right, right.
I think this could make sense.
So, I thought that Tarush had
to be younger than Arman.
But no, Tarush is 5 times 153.
So Tarush is actually
765 years old.
We should call him Methuselah.
So, Tarush is 765 years old.
And then if we go 85 years into
the past, Tarush would have
been-- what did we say?
If we go 85 years into the
past, so let's write this down.
This is equal to, I'm about to
run out of time, so you might
have to check this yourself.
If that's equal to 153,
then 5x is equal to 765.
These numbers are big.
And then 153 minus 85.
Well, 155 minus 85 would be 73.
So this would be 72.
And then Tarush, 85 years ago.
No, I think I messed
up someplace.
Well, actually, I only have
ten seconds before YouTube
won't let me upload it.
So we'll have to stop there.
Thank you.